[Musique]
nouvelle édition devait y paie sur tv 78
bienvenu merci de nous rejoindre bonjour
à thibaut armangau bonjour vous êtes
notre invité aujourd'hui on va évoquer
votre activité professionnelle un peu
particulière on va y venir et puis
parler aussi de votre parcours votre
famille et on va débuter d'ailleurs avec
ce sujet là votre grand-père et gilles
bérard bangas était consul dans les
années 1930 1940 il fut le premier à
refuser de prêter serment à pétain
lorsqu'il était en poste à mexico vous
nous raconter un peu cette histoire est
normalement on devrait voir voilà et on
la voit cette image est qui et qui les
représentent du coup votre grand père
justement
voilà qui était à mexico en poste
d'ambassadeur aux usa et au mexique au
caire aussi à lisbonne et bas pendant
l'occupation donc
comme dans l'histoire de france on que
c'était mashaal pétain donc
pétain lui avait demandé d'aller prêter
et salué son confrère ambassadeur à
mexico
allemand et donc ma mon grand-père
commencé déjà la résistance il est l
europe qui est hors de question pardon
que j'aille saluer l'ambassadeur
allemand donc le maréchal pétain
la robe et ses fonctions d'ici dix à
l'ambassadeur pendant l'occupation qui a
été relevé de ses fonctions et cet
engagement il l'a transmis aussi à votre
père serge 1943 18 ans il s'engage dans
la guerre avec la france libre c'est ça
en partant de mexico ils ont traversé la
manche
jeudi en bateau et ils ont été reçus à
new york ils ont traversé new-york
pardon ils ont été reçus à londres par
le général de gaulle du 18 juin suite
après le 10 juin 40 et pape avait 16 17
ans voilà et donc
le général de gaulle a créé l'école des
cadets de la france libre dames doubles
et voilà tout à fait on les voit où je
suis allé moi-même 60 ans après bien sûr
visiter cette école et mon père a fait
le débarquement à courses aide et il a
libéré metz nancy saint malo à 18 ans il
était vice consul en allemagne à 20 ans
il organise et les maquis en france
oui si on veut mais il interrogé sur
tous les ss etc il faut savoir
dans ce qui se passe comme en ukraine si
vous voulez y en a qui
changent des uniformes qui m'avait
vêtements civils et puis il se met dans
la masse voilà mon père était tout jeune
comme des jeunes au lycée il y avait 64
mille jeunes comme lui conjointe de
gourdes et un sur quatre sont morts au
combat
et
ils interrogeaient les c'est 150 ans
dans le vent les vêtements les avaient
sous l'aisselle les deux aces marquer
voilà déjà permettait de savoir s'il a
fait diversion aussi ses engagements
très forts forcément politiquement
historiquement de votre grand-père puis
de votre père ils vous ont forgé marquer
on en parlait en famille et ça ça
représente quoi aujourd'hui pour vous
d'éducation je suis né dans ce milieu là
les valeurs de la france la république
le devoir le respect ce qui est
important je pense que c'est des valeurs
qu'il faut perpétuer que je perpétue
aussi
à mon fils et auprès des personnes que
je peux croiser ça donne les repères ça
permet de relativiser aussi donc pour
répondre à votre question oui j'ai été
baigné lmnp j'ai fait le tour du monde
j'ai été à moscou avec mon père j'ai été
en allemagne j'ai plein d'anecdotes là
dessus là je vais faire une conférence
justement aux mureaux dans un collège là
au mois d'avril pour expliquer en tant
que petit fils d'ambassadeur et fizi
d'officiers des françaises est libre
existe des rails mon père était aussi au
directeur de cabinet d'andré malraux
aussi voilà donc si vous voulez oui j'ai
été élevé l'inde en egée est élevé à
l'international parce qu'elle a mon père
parler cette langue donc si vous voulez
on a reçu de toutes les nationalités
en europe et dans le monde à la maison
donc ça vous donne une ouverture
d'esprit il y aura un hommage aussi
j'aurai le préciser à verneuil une rue
qui devrait prochainement pardon porter
le nom c'est de votre père alors oui des
cadets de la france libre ce dont je
viens d'expliquer un conjoint de gaulle
comme papa avec 48 ans à vern sur scène
c'était le seul officier de la ville
et c'est le maire fabien au frigidaire
va rendre hommage à mon père le 24
septembre et la rue des quêtes de la
france libre serge armand gaz 18 juin 40
on va parler de vous à proprement parler
maintenant votre parcours est très
diversifiée vous êtes un autodidacte
c'est comme ça que vous vous êtes
définis quand on a échangé avant cette
émission je vais dresser les quelques
professions vous avez exercé professeur
de golf responsable commercial dans les
télécommunications responsable des
relations publiques d'un cabinet d'audit
et aujourd'hui vous avez une entreprise
de conseils parlez-nous un peu de votre
parcours oui bon moi j'ai
chez autodidacte dans le sens mal je
n'ai pas très doué pour les études donc
je me suis fait tout seul dans le sens
géant siéger facebook de golf voilà je
l'enseigné golf pendant plus de 20 ans
et pour des raisons personnelles j'ai
arrêté donc ça m'a permis aussi par mon
milieu non de me construire aussi un
carnet d'adressés le golf et les
relations publiques le mois là et mon
idée était souvent je m'étais déjà en
rapport
voilà sciences humaines
on va dire par mon intermédiaire mais il
faisait des affaires donc au bout d'un
moment je me suis dit un peu idiot la
monteux projet un parent etc des
affaires centre voilà donc c'est là où
j'ai eu l'idée si vous voulez de monter
organisation à mon cabinet de conseil en
développement d'affaires où je fais du
premium
je perds mais si vous voulez aux
entreprises sur l'île de france sur le
département des yvelines de développer
leurs affaires dans le sens
économiquement
c'est un coup beaucoup moins cher que
des commerciaux sur le terrain
parce que quand vous prenez des
commerciaux ce qui est très bien moi
j'ai rien contre ils sont là pour
développer on a un besoin mais il ya des
charges sociales l'économie comme tout
le monde le sait ce que coûte assez cher
moi je prends des honoraires et je leur
garantis d'un rendez-vous premium avec
des décideurs ce qui leur permet sous
les gagne du temps il avant des
résultats quelle est la véritable plus
value cessé de gagner du temps c'est ça
oui c'est de gagner du temps c'est des
prises de rendez-vous direct
je fais aussi
tout ce qui est développement de
communication relations publiques
événements aussi
donc c'est à dire le mandater pages et
des partenaires avec qui je travaille
actuellement aussi donc
on va dire je vais faire sourire on va
dire que je suis un peu passe partout
voilà dans le sens doublé porte c'est un
gars du temps
avec des prisons du possible et donc je
suis l'ambassadeur séoul et de mes
partenaires
je représente
divers secteurs d'activités qui
correspond à leur demande et aujourd'hui
combien de clients j'ai quatre
entreprises quatre entreprises que vous
représentez à la et qui ont pu
développer un peu justement leur
relation leur chiffre d'affaires pour
ces entreprises pas les cartes que vous
suivez forcément mais plus globalement
aujourd'hui la situation entre la
situation post qu'ovide la situation en
ukraine aussi s'attend ça complique le
business des entreprises par ça dépend
lesquels certaines oui d'autres non faut
savoir que
l'économie un peu reparti même avec la
crise économique
du pouvoir d'achat mais je dors dans le
sens si vous voulez les créations
d'emplois remonte donc
il n'y a pas eu de trop si vous voulez
de perturbations selon mes informations
pour l'instant son département des
yvelines mais les entretiens je peux
avoir avec les pdg les directeurs les
tpe les pme excellent avec qui je
travaille
sont dans la société une rentabilité
c'est un autre débat mon père parlait
c'est une rentabilité c'est des
résultats assez rapide ils préfèrent
avoir des personnes comme d'expérience
aussi
et qui peuvent cibler leurs produits et
pas avoir des intermédiaires tout le
temps on prenait un commercial qui va
faire du folie où il est le barrage de
la secrétaire ou etc
donc c'est là où j'interviens nous
appeler en direct voilà ça marche
beaucoup mieux
et que l'entreprise et je fais le suivi
je fais la mise en place j'accompagne
mon client en rendez vous etc
l'entreprise s'appelle organisation à
quels sont vos projets un peu de
développement et par la suite pour cette
activité abbas et de là j'ai dû
embaucher une assistance donc après
c'est voir si je peux
prendre des deux ou trois consultants
avec moi aussi
pour le suivi pour le développement si
j'ai bien suivi au début c'était un
statut auto entreprise c'est encore le
cas aujourd'hui où vous avez l'âge et le
cas passés en sas non je suis en
construction de sites internet aussi
donc voilà je juge sur les réseaux
linkedin google pour l'instant mais tout
ça est en train de se développer en ce
moment est ce que c'est une activité et
sel comme la vôtre qui tend à se
développer justement et connaissent bien
des états unis brûlent pourquoi puisque
dans le sens que j'ai une très bonne
relation sur les états unis et au canada
qui me titille bouttier dans la lumière
la battue ça marcherait ingénieux parce
que là bas il ya un autre état d'esprit
c'est à dire que ne vont pas regarder
votre parcours où ils vont ils regardent
la personne bien sûr qu'ils vont sentir
à droite à gauche mais il marche
énormément pas raison c'est comme dans
le golfe si vous voulez nos états unis
le golf est un sport très populaire
comme le foot en france voilà est bien
là bas les hommes d'affaires au canada
ou aux états unis comment il fonctionne
ils vont ils vont fonctionner par réseau
en jouant au golf et ils font leurs
affaires sur les greens mouvement là moi
je le fais autrement je le fais par
téléphone et prise de rendez vous donc
c'est vrai qu'en france on reste encore
où c'est l'image où ils se disent
nous on va vous prendre en tant
qu'apporteur d'affaires à la commission
moi je ne fonctionne pas comme ça j'ai
passé l'âge et 50 ans etc
s'ils veulent atteindre telle personne
c'est du temps c'est du travail c'est
que c'est commun que cette l'ambassadeur
de clients qui me mandate donc sa voix
que je fonctionne avec des honoraires
mais qui sont des coudes dix fois moins
cher qu'un commercial
cette façon de fonctionner plus à
l'américaine
c'est bénéfique et c'est un frein en
france notre façon de fonctionner dans
un entretien que j'ai avec des patrons
oui c'est un frein mais souvent ils me
rappellent apprendre de moi ok on va
finalement dévolue voilà où alors expert
comptable et le lcd mais c'est quand
même plus rentable et au sein de la
mentalité blessés oui pour revenir à la
mentalité des chefs qui certains jeux
entreprises mais généralisée c'est plus
plus tôt
on va dire apporteur d'affaires et je ne
paye pas donnant rien quoi voilà même
moi je ne travaille pas avec des
entreprises comme celle ci oui puisque
vous avez échangé aux directement avec
les entreprises au sein du medef vous y
avez collaboré aussi rien on au cabinet
du président du medef des yvelines aussi
voilà permet de développer votre réseau
et si en plus on va arriver à la fin de
cet entretien juste une dernière
question on est en pleine campagne
électorale donc on va éviter de parler
véritablement d'engagement politique
néanmoins vous vous étiez tout de même
lancé sur une liste aux municipales à
verneuil vous avez été aussi candidat au
départemental si on reprend un peu votre
votre parcours juste pour résumer ça
nous fait revenir un petit peu à ce
qu'on disait au début de cet échange
vous êtes un bouliste oui fier de lait
pour faire clair ça a été un visionnaire
quand on parle de la souveraineté macro
lien en pleine danse de gaulle l'avait
dit il faut je dis aux françaises et aux
français lisent et le fil de l'épée du
général de gaulle
on terminera là dessus merci beaucoup
aux employeurs en gaz d'être venu pour
sauver gakpé on se retrouve bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]